so cameras were not allowed in the
courtroom today or obviously we'd have a
lot of amazing footage for you but we do
have some idea of what jesse smallett
was saying because he hasn't really
changed what he has been saying for the
past three years so back in 2019 he
argued that
only racist
wouldn't take his story at face value
if i had said
it was a muslim or mexican
or someone black i feel like the
doubters would have supported me a lot
much more a lot more
and that says a lot about the place that
we are in our country right now
the fact that we have these fear mongols
these people that are
trying to separate us
and
it's just not okay
fear mongrels
they were a problem then they're a
problem now candace owens is the host of
candice she's been following all this
for a couple years now she joins us with
her reaction candace it is great to see
today what do you make of this
oh wow i mean honestly i make that his
um his defense should have actually said
pled insanity and i would have bought it
like when you listen to the story and
you really follow every element of this
like jesse smaller is not a sane person
and what people are forgetting is that
he's asking you to believe you know
there's this thing called occam's razor
right usually the simplest explanation
is the best explanation he is asking you
to believe just an incredible set of
circumstances took place here he wants
you to believe how many black people do
you think go through two hate crimes in
one week that somebody sent him a letter
to onset like the zodiac killer right
cutting out every single letter and it
was from you know signed magga right
because this was all about donald trump
was signed magga the police say actually
this came from jesse right and then just
five days later jesse smallett goes to
get a subway sandwich and some eggs at
walgreens at 1 am in the morning on a
frigid night and what do you know some
mega supporters jump out he doesn't
recognize the voice of his lover right
the person that he has a sexual
relationship with right he wants you to
believe all of these circumstances his
lovers lying on him he didn't he
couldn't see at night that these were
actually two tall nigerian black men uh
the police department has it against him
the person that was in the ride-along um
is lying about what happened he never
said they were wearing a maga hat the
police chief is lying on him i mean you
have to be an absolute fool to believe
anything else than what is plainly in
front of us jesse smullett lied it is
actually the greatest racial hoax that
has taken place at least in the last
three decades right he should face way
deeper charges that he's facing right
now way steeper charges it's actually in
my opinion kim fox should be on the
stand you know for less than the charge
that are against him
well so you wonder i mean
what's so in i guess the infuriating
part of this is look you got caught
you're busted you did it
it's kind of insulting to the rest of us
to pretend you didn't when clearly you
did and moreover you wonder
what percentage of the population will
believe that he was framed or whatever
absolutely nobody believes this nobody
believes this but jesse and the people
that want him to get off and his
solution is i told a really big lie so
i'm just going to tell an even bigger
lie to try to get away with it right i'm
going to move from one conspiracy theory
to the next and the last thing i'll say
here tucker is just imagine if the races
will reverse imagine if two white men
pretended that two black men had
attacked them what would the media be
saying right now what would be the
charges what would be the demands right
now this is incredibly racist what he
did right incredibly racist meant to
cause racial division in this country at
the end of the day he's going to get a
light tap on the wrist if he even gets
that
i would never defend any of this and i
wish robin roberts of
abc the ever credulous was on the stand
today let's see if she's changed her
mind about this candace oh but she
hasn't great to see you thank you so
much
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else